What should we do when Ramadan
approaches? The first thing we should do
is we should thank Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala for making us witness this
blessed month of Ramadan once again. And
we have to thank him for his mercy. And
we have to ask forgiveness in this month
so that all our previous sins will be
forgiven.
And we have to thank him for all the
nyamat he has given us, all the
blessings, all the love. This is the
best month. And Allah subhanana wa tala
says in the Quran in surah bakar chapter
number two verse number 185 it says
which means that Ramadan is the month in
which the Quran was revealed as a
guidance for mankind
and signs
for guidance and judgment between right
and wrong. And Allah further says in the
Quran in surah Bakar chapter number two
verse number 183 Allah says
oh you who believe
oh you who believe fasting was
prescribed to you as it was prescribed
to people who came before you. So that
you may learn
self-restraint.
The word used here is
similar to tawa. So that you learn god
consciousness. So that you learn piety.
So that you learn righteousness. So this
is the month in which a person can
become more righteous. This is the time
when a tawa can be the highest. And this
is a month. It is an annual training. It
is a sort of an overhauling of the body.
How we have that every machinery
requires some sort of servicing maybe
every 3 months, maybe every year. And if
you allow me to call the human beings as
the best machinery in the world, doesn't
it require a servicing or overhauling?
So Ramadan is an annual overhauling of
the human body. It is a spiritual and
moral training for the human being and
it is a purification of the body, mind
and soul. This is the month where we can
increase our tawa. We can increase our
patience and we can derive the benefits
and the guidance from the Quran. Subhan
Allah.